[Music]
it's not a free-agent destination
they're not going to be in the market
Charlotte for a list guys if you're the
Charlotte Hornets is letting go of Kimba
going to be beneficial for you if he
goes it's like starting over the
community loves Kemba Walker he does
things the right way
he's a leader he is the perfect guy to
lead your franchise I'm just a team
player I'm having fun teammates when
they do great things you know I'm just
happy yeah that's who I am
it's all about how Charlotte builds
around him Campbell Walker like he's
developed into an all-star he's always
been as swar chemists rific I love what
he planned everybody's always plotted
gets then becomes the play every night
the Charlotte Bobcats select Kemble
we're here with Kendall Walker who's
getting a whole lot of attention pretty
solid rookie year how's the treat get so
far through the first half of the season
oh pretty well I'm just trying to get
better
no everyday
[Music]
I really think they can build around
Kimball walk I think he is that good
he's that much he is that dynamic it's a
lot easier to build when you've got
something to build with a foundation
Kimball is their foundation
it pops Charlotte I don't know that I
want to use that guy
the grass with this much pigment Walker
Charlotte's all-time leading scorer you
know I gotta I gotta bring it every day
I gotta bring it every night you know I
have to be on point each and every night
in my leadership as I go about my team
go I don't know what's going on behind
closed doors but they're probably
considering you know listen for the
rebuild Charlotte is a little bit more
of a sensitive market
Kemba Walker really good player in his
prime is reportedly available
I'm not as big or you know athletic as
those other guys you know my heart is
definitely one of the things that gave
me over the hump a my passion for the
game when you get hot like that the
great players to continue to stay on
their rollin to hunt their shot because
they know they can have a special night
Kimble got hotter like
forward a certain amount of time left
and third if not the tough guy had 58
out of the time out you know where the
ball was going he was that moment he's
been watering this page
[Applause]
he had going in
we thought every shot that he blew up
what's going in I just think rebuild is
where they are because this team is not
meeting their expectations I put my
heart and soul into this team and into
the city so for the third time he's an
all-star but for the first time he has
heard his name called as a starter
making third team as we talked about
means Walker is eligible to be paid as
much as 221 million dollars by the
wardens it's kind of surreal you know I
had a lot of doubt coming into my early
career about just even being the elite
point guard in this league
I think the Lakers would love to have
Walker in their lineup Kimball Walker he
would fit in like that cuz man you could
put the ball in his hands but how do you
say no to 80 million if you're kimba I
think New York would be a good option
but I could see that happening I mean
I've been there for the last several
years and it was a place where I got my
opportunity place where I got my start
you've done all the right things of
making
feel this is the place to be for the
rest of his career this is the business
of basketball